Hello everybody! It's time for me to FLEX on you kids again!!
Have you seen my "view 10"? Look at this baby. (Felix's child confrmrned???)
It has the pick up and wake up feature where I literally don't have to press a button to unlock it. (lazy boi)
(noises and winking sound effect) (poods beautiful face entered here)(wink wonk)
Wow it's almost like you don't have to pay a thousand dollars for this feature, (almost!)
iNcReDiBlE!
But I know what you're thinking, but Felix. What if I have a psycho girlfriend who will use it on me when I am asleep? (here Felix is begging for help through subtle hints)
Don't worry!! (intense music plays)
That's right, it doesn't unlock if you're sleeping! (what a great feauture!)
*Nervous Laugh* (more like gay laugh from poods but okay)
Thank God. (Poods is still asking for help to get away from Marzia)
it even covers my most advanced testing!     (and by "advanced testing" Poods means becoming a woman with one simple trick, making him look extra gay)
(Advanced testing ongoing)
Clearly this is the superior. If you want a view ten we're doing a !!🎉 giveaway 🎉 !!
That's right. Three winners will win a prize pack which contains one honor view ten and an honor band. (also I will own the souls of the winners but we'll get back to that later)
The honor band works with a face unlock as well. It's got 30 days usage of one charge
Incredible!
Waterproof
And tracks your sleeping data! (watches you while you sleep)
This contest is between April 15 and 20 check out the link in the description for more info.
Now let's go on with a video guys (finally)
HmmmMMmmmmmM
HHhmmmmmm?
Hm? (hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm indeed)
You ever see something online that gives you that expression that feeling that you just can't express with words, and you just have to go
HmMMmmmMm (the PewDiePie channel in a nutshell)
That is pretty interesting. Of course you have. But today in case you haven't we're going to review with some
HmmMmm Like worthy moments so we can go HHmmmMMm
together, you and me as a fun little exercise! I bet you don't have any friends. (makes sizzling noise in attempt to nervously laugh)
Let's review the HmMmM Reddit!
HMMMMMM
I hate when they're sexual, it's just weird.
*mumbles*
They're not sexual! Youtube, I'm sorry, I was just kidding. It was a joke. It's just water. It's just water now.
Now that's sexual HMMM hehehhe ah.
How does that make any... this really shows the reflection of water crisis?
What am I saying?
Those are not his eyes? Those are not spider-man's eyes?
(grunting and explosion sound effect)
My whole life is a lie!!
How can I possibly look at spider-man the same way if he doesn't look back at me with those spidey eyes?
hmmmmmmmm
I almost died out of "hmmm-ing."
If the mouse is outside of the presentation. Was the mouse even really there?
Hmmmm (Starts to cry)
This is so S*** hehehe (mega oof)
(Majestic laugh)
How am I supposed to react to this?
I mean it was a good Photoshop, but it doesn't make Hmm, alright.
I'd be lying if I said this makes me hmm. This makes me..
Mmmm
(Dramatic Gasp)
He is  a bomb defuser and he's playing Minesweeper.
Nothing really hmMming about it. It's more like, well that's funny, I suppose.
WHEEEEZE
Now that's
MMMM
Finally. I hate, guys, I hate Twilight. I don't know if I ever expressed this properly on this channel, but
FFFFFF
Twilight is just a cringiest dumbest vampire show and doesn't have real superheroes like Black Panther here
Hmmm Hehehehehehe
HMMMMRNNNNN
This is so nice to finally see a progressive police woman, whaman.
That, uhhhh,
Carries not guns but carrots. But who came first the horse or the carrot?
HMMMMM
Obviously the carrot, like, let's not even be silly here
(wheeze)
(strange laugh)
What am I looking at???
Guys let's freaking, this is my song, this is my jam. Come on guys. Let's get going.
(strange sound)
HMMMMMMMMM
Hmm
I didn't know that actually... oh I see (gasp).
HMMM. I wonder if that actually works.
Hnnnnn
You ever wonder why I don't shave? Okay, this is the reason why.
Hehehe
It's called it's called not having a proper jawline, alright.
HmmMMMmMMmMM
HMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM (hmmm intensifies)
Wow, that is interesting. It's nice to see emojis being so progressive!
Uhhhh
Finally we have an emoji for everything.
Now what the frick is this?
This is not hmm
Get your garbage fantasies out of Hmm, okay?
It's upsetting.  Here I am trying to Hmm at things, and I'm just stuck with this.
(grunting) Weeze hmMMmM
Now this is sexy
Now that's sexy
If only Marzia
Look like this
If only Marzia would look this good!
If only Marzia
Marzia
IF ONLY... MARZIA
What ah (Door CREAAAAAKS)
Yes? -Marzia
(Baby hmmmm)
hmm.
What am I supposed to say? This is such a dumb video. Why did you guys want me to make another one of these?
Mmm. There you go
Mmm. See, I don't understand when more people don't do this.
Any time I'm in the urinal people go as far away from me as possible.
But I'm like we could save water if we all just put our (age-restricted) together.
(laughing wheeze)
There this is why you shouldn't smoke, kids. I mean look at this man, why is Hmmmm?
Hmm is mixed with such a strange
Feeling you know you feel these urges from hmm-ing. There's no shame in feeling that
Is that real?
mm-hmm
So that's what they use for. I always thought I should just put my bag on those! *Sniff* that looks fantastically great.
Okay, I don't see the HMMM right away like give me a second here.
That's Jesus Christ (which one)
HMhmhhahhahmmah
So much better whether you don't see it right away
How can I tell if i have
HMMMMM
If you check Google right now and you see this exact image then
HMMMMMN
HMMMMM INTENSIFIES
This is me when I play Fortnite cuz these are all kids. That's right
Come at me kids, what are you gonna do? (beat your skull against a rock) Jesus Christ stop these weird photo shops okay? No one is Hmm-ing  at them
DEMONITIZED
HMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM heh
Such a dumb video Jesus Christ, no is that real
No (this person fucked up their dog)
NO
This is also another reason why you should never shave okay, right here.
Now that's hmmmmmmmm
Slippy
Slippy this is a live footage of Slippy traveling into the other realm. (it's actually footage of Slippy sexually assulting another being)
Bless his soul mm-hmm a uniform hmm for respect of Slippy
Is that those thing you iron? Does that mean it's an iron plate?
Hmmm? HMMMMMM?
Who's enjoying the book more prime hmm if I saw a toilet like that
I Would take down my pants. I would squat down and I would go *Constipated hmmm*
So Bad
I am the worst
Ah yes. I don't know if you guys have heard about the turtle in the wall theory
But this pretty much confirms
That all walls have a turtle living in them hmm (obviously)
Taha. HMMMmmMmM *Clap Clap Clap*
Now somebody's finally doing right (agreed)
Which one do you make a poopy in?
Hmm, which one, would you choose? mmm a true Hmmm dilemma
Hmmmmmm. HMMMMMMmmm
Hmm a uniform hmm
That's right even lizard people go to Hmm
Finally we have some evidence for this
He's a robot by the way open your eyes. Okay. There's nothing to confirm that he's a lizard
I've seen this this is so insane like
Why did you have to photoshoppe this why?
angry HMMMM
That's right every single time I watch Titanic I'm like he can just go up
So stupid this really shows sexism, and how it's bad for men as well
Damn Daniel he's rocking it damn. He looks good
What in the world
Hmm sometimes clothing likes to Hmm back at you
mm-hmm
This is the worst video of all time
No now I can never look at H&M the same way
*Painful Hmmm*
God damn it this changes everything
DRGSAMFGBNG
What a great idea and you can keep the trucks running for warm hmm, yeah
Come we never thought of this before, huh?
HUUUUHH...HUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUh
Wasn't that just a great experience? we all need a little Hmmm in our life
Don't you think leave a like if you Hmm believe you're like if you HMMMM
And I'll see you guys next time in the next video
(applause)